how's it going bros my name is and this
is my hair
let's check out the memes
[Music]
jack sent me this
you know that is illegal in italy it's
not ella
i asked marci is it illegal and she said
no it's only in the south they
they care but i care i'm with him i hate
when they
uh when they they do that to the
palestine all right what do we got
oh no
what bruh it's lasagna
23 minutes ago [ __ ] three years ago
blurry hail man that's crazy
time passes
what some people say i look like marzia
and i figured out
what yeah that's very similar
that's tricky there can only be one get
out me every time i sit in front of this
type of fan
i can't believe that made me laugh it's
so bad
i had really bad me who got the most
uploaded image for the thumbnail
where you've been bamboozled
you win played i used it for the
thumbnail one time and then i realized
i don't want to use that image why
change when we already have perfection
guys
look i'm doing it it's great
man pewdiepie it was so nice meeting you
yeah yeah
yeah yeah all right what do we have here
excuse me good sir i would like to file
a complaint we were promised that
pewdiepie's new thumbnail reaction phase
would be picked out by reddit reddit has
chosen yet the reaction phase is still
the same
i'm upset right it is upset when can we
expect the correct
face to be in the thumbnail hi this is
me by customers
you're currently in position 52 please
hold
can't do this no more i quit all gonna
be okay i'm sorry you're doing a great
job
yeah side fired from customer service
sorry no service package
no cybe quit so no service packet needed
sorry
bye oh my
they do the same pose other content
creators thumbnails
[Laughter]
oh that should be my new one i like that
i've drank piss at some point in my life
finally
a worthy opponent yes share your
spill the beans i've also drank piss so
this means nothing to me
petition for felix to break pasta in
front of marxis to see her action she
doesn't care
she does it she doesn't ah
close it up and break your pasta like
the savage you are
yeah i wear the pants streamers what the
f is this [ __ ]
fbs i should get a new processor me 11
fps
still playable i can still enjoy this i
notice a
mild drop in frames here male female
i get it because i play minecraft and i
have basic
uh as a chemistry knowledge
wow acknowledging that your favorite
youtube address is a bad product for
money doesn't make you a bad fan
yeah i agree who is this youtuber you
mentioned
me don't use opera what's wrong with
opera
i'm literally using opera right now
that's this [ __ ] internet explorer
gang
they just won't leave me alone by
helping my brother through the hospital
wish your brother speeder recovery
people hating on him in their comments
israeli has some interesting opinions
sometimes not gonna lie is it always
bright in sweden
yeah during mid-summer yes it is it's
really tricky especially when you're
young and you're out partying all night
and the sun just never goes down
i don't know where which city this is it
i definitely seem brighter uh summer
days as well
[Music]
is this cycle the thing is this is
really cool right
but the thing is that also means the
winters are
super uh dark and it's honestly
so depressing having to go to school and
it's pitch black out
right and then you come back from school
and it's already getting dark and you're
like [ __ ]
it's you sweden yeah prank finally got
to visit toronto's greatest attraction
i can't believe it's still there i need
to go back to toronto just to see it
the best attraction in toronto it's
quite central too
it's like on a really popular shopping
street hell yeah oppo that's big peepee
right there
this i can understand god damn
[Applause]
oh yeah look at those thighs look at
those thighs man
i like it i like it a lot how tall is
jontron 510
[Laughter]
i'm not 511 i'm at least six nine
at least and y'all can't prove otherwise
so i don't understand why this is even a
discussion
you guys want to see uh how i look like
without my shoes on
there it is i only take off the weights
to reveal my final power i was wearing
the weights underneath the whole time
youtuber with 10 million subs 12k
pewdiepie with 110 million subs
480p take it or leave it yeah that seems
about right you really
need to watch this face in higher
quality do you want to see my pores that
badly is this what this is about
[ __ ] camera's even crooked
4k mate no no
and i gotta be honest i'll watch linux
in in 12k
i want a holographic linus at my house
so i can see him every day
not gonna lie doorbell rings who is it
shop
baby girl it's your boy
came back he came back oh wait they did
it oh my gosh yes
let's go g fueling zero g
baby it happened
sick i'm so jealous
they go up in double gravity here they
[Music]
go
this is huge it's whoa
shave like that 10 out of 10.
that's so cool guys i'm so happy to
announce that
uh to you that i officially trusted you
to swedish wow congratulations
all right let's not turn this reddit
into something that people will say it's
a transfer week
okay only i can be swedish stop it
i'm the only one some people say i look
like felix i figured i'd ask
people on here i personally don't see
the wrist that
ugly [ __ ] looks nothing like me get him
out of my sight
making ikea swedish meatballs at home
but better
uh the entirety of sweden watching this
you dare oppose me more too i mean yeah
kia meeples aren't bad by all means but
they're not
they're not good meatballs so uh
no offense taken here you get to live
the dark age
we don't talk about that it's funny
seeing it all together
dude that furby caused the fire alarm
and the whole building had to evacuate
that was a menace okay and things are
better now i'm happier
hell yeah let's go the world is a cruel
and unjust
place there is no harmony in the
universe the only constant is suffering
oh my god oh that's so sweet
i feel the same way when i'm recording a
video until i see a bad mean
then we go back to square one talking
about setting the shower
talking about drinking paste but i have
also drank piss so that must mean that
kfc
ksi has also showered
tell us hello jj share your
story there's no shame oh cute
about i'mma keep it real with your peers
i ain't installing a gaming browser
that's fine i don't care
i was picking strawberries at work and i
found a bro face
well that's actually kind of tricky
i like it okay now that we made armor
for both of them
oh so they did one for critical as well
[Laughter]
we need to battle of course we need to
cross swords
hell yeah so i drew edgar for 10 hours
straight i named this one the council of
demonetization i really hope felix can
see this so help me out guys
love it it's glorious edgar's not that
fat
come on come on you did him dirty
europeans still hate
jarrah soda yeah i remember that it was
awful
i think simon said that it was like an
acquired taste or something
there you go it's good for your health
spice is good for your health
[Laughter]
that ain't it that is not it oh
i don't know if i've already seen this i
feel like i have but it's worth seeing
again i love it
handy the hand amazing job it's like
you're so
cute
oh man and again when pewdiepie starts
the video
[Laughter]
oh bless him i will make a video with
edgar this week
i've been putting it out for too long
and i'll show you
there's nothing to be threatened about
[ __ ] man
all right guys thanks for watching and
another episode of friday's repair
if you enjoyed consider subscribe see
you next video
rufus